I think for the people to realize that
this is America's Our Moment of cultural
revolution is happening this is a silent
revolution in happening classrooms in
corporate businesses in the media it's
happening everywhere and we just don't
see it and media is lying to us they are
changing entire Dynamic of this country
we are somehow hate speeches of violence
therefore you have no right to speak
your mind and that's not the definition
of freedom people don't even understand
what it means to be American and they
are Americans like I became a citizen
last year and in my students test my
interview asking me have you ever
persecuted anybody for their poor
opinion if I said yes I could not become
American and that's what Google does
that's what Facebook does what Instagram
does and they were used to Twitter them
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the author of the brand new book while
time remains a North Korean defectors
search for freedom in North America my
friend janmi Park welcome back to the
Reuben report thank you for having me
back Beyond me last time I saw you was
in Chicago Illinois you were living in
Chicago at the time and you opened for
me on the don't burn this country book
tour we did a matinee show at the
Chicago improv and uh I didn't tell you
you had to be funny but you crushed it
you did like 10 minutes of Freedom
loving stand-up comedy and you crushed
it my friend
oh thank you that was the most fun thing
I've ever done in my life so I'm very
grateful
did you ever think if you would have
gone to your life uh you know 15 years
ago in North Korea that you'd be doing a
little stand-up comedy in Chicago a
couple years later
this is the thing like this year was
beyond anything that I knew
a new word I did not even know what
was and for instance I mean I thought of
Americans as you know Cold Blood
reptiles monsters right never knew in my
latte I was going to be hanging out with
Americans and you know make some jokes
yeah it was it was really just
absolutely wonderful one of the most
memorable ones for me so so I don't want
to go into your whole story again which
you have now not only did you write your
first book about but you've obviously
told so many times over we'll put a link
to it down below so people can get a
full recap of your story but in essence
you in a in a really just unbelievable
way you defected from North Korea you've
you eventually made it to the United
States and really what you're doing now
and I think what this book is about is
really warning people that so many of
the signs that you saw in North Korea uh
are happening in the United States right
now is that is that a fair estimation of
how this book really shapes out
yeah absolutely I think most people do
get really shocked that you know how
dare you compare companies create to
America and of course I'm not comparing
the living standards are the same
however the the tactics the tactics the
North Korean use to control people and
brainwashing ones was the same tactics
that I'm seeing right now in current
America and more and more every single
day living in Chicago New York City I
see this country getting destroyed so
one of the things that's interesting is
you've described in the past how you
know basically getting mugged on the
streets that was in Chicago right yeah
and and then these false cries of racism
because the people who mugged you happen
to be black women and just all of this
sort of nonsense related to cancel
culture but then it really got escalated
under covid right because it wasn't just
silencing people because someone was
calling you racist then it was really
government designed uh silencing
absolutely and during the pandemic as
like everything was cancer it I wanted
to make videos about the plight of North
Korean women how they're being raped and
Their audience harvests out in China on
the commons party and when I talk about
this women's plight in China my videos
get demonetized censored and get shot
opened all the social media platforms
and I reached out to Google like do you
guys not supported me too or something
right that's all about it like right
believe her believe what women say and
why would they not supporting this
women's pride of North Koreans under
China Commons party and they said simply
it does not meet our guidelines
and I mean during the time I was raising
two years old toddler and she now you're
being a father you understand how
powerless that I felt Living in America
I thought the best thing that I've ever
done was giving my son the U.S passport
make him to born in the field of freedom
but during the pandemic when I send him
to daycare his teachers would make sure
that he would wear a mask up to here
eight hours a day to two years old who
just barely learning how to run and
walking and then they were opening strip
clubs next door
and like bars opening and then they
would lock down the children's
playground but the dog parks were open
and I was thinking somehow the dogs have
more rights than my child in America
right now right they have freedom to go
to park and run around Under the Sun but
my son couldn't and I think that's when
I really realized how powerless I was as
an individual I never thought that I was
going to be locked indoor my son would
have to put a mask like that and
couldn't go even eating in the
restaurant like that it must have been
doubly jarring for you because having
come from a place where people couldn't
say what they think and neighbors were
afraid of neighbors and everything else
suddenly you're confronted with this
again what do you think about was it
shocking to you that in a place where
freedom is supposedly so important how
quickly everyone quote unquote behaved
yeah I think in the name of Public
Health how everybody just lost any
Common Sense any any mind of their own
but the thing is the government's the
mainstream media was playing this fear
tactic to the people right they were
just saying how as if the copies the
dead deadly virus and lying to people
and so many children that I had with my
son their mothers would not let their
child out for two years inside this like
the apartment condo their child never
seen the someone in their life for two
years we don't even know what that
effect is and how easily people get
brainwashed it's like North Korea during
the BLM protests and the Looting my
mother visiting in Chicago and we're
just hearing his guns shooting
everything and then we turned on CNN and
BBC and all the mainstream media I said
there was really no violence it was
mostly peaceful mostly peaceful that's
what they say yes and then we could not
go buy the milk because they were losing
the grocery stores literally that we
could not even buy the milk and those
the mainstream media just lies to
American people and if they were not
living in Chicago downtown they would
not have known what we went through yeah
and I would have previously and if I
were not living in Chicago right so you
you eventually left Chicago and and made
your way to New York New York's got its
own set of problems but it it seems to
be a little bit better than Chicago
right in terms of that maybe yeah a
little bit better but as an Asian woman
there's a huge a hate Asian crime like
literally whenever I take the subway I
know that I'm risking my own life taking
the subway
and why is it so Grim or is that when I
was escaping from North Korea and China
I had at least a place to escape to that
was America there was a free country
there waiting for me I am scared every
day for my son because if America Falls
I cannot imagine the world without
America where would my son escape to for
Freedom there's no place left is there a
weird thing sort of psychologically for
you where when you were escaping North
Korea we've talked about in the past in
some ways you didn't even know what you
were escaping because you had lived in
that cave so to speak so you didn't know
what was on the outside of that cave
here where you see the authoritarianism
coming you didn't expect it here so I
would imagine in a weird way it's it's
almost worse seeing it here it's Allah
hopeless you know I'd say because I know
I see the map of the world right in
North Korea the nasty map of the world I
did not know what was possible now in
the world I see the internet seeing all
the human history and Korean words I
know what's possible and America is the
best chance my favorite God as a
Humanity this is a Humanity's hope this
is the best country in human entire
history and people cannot be happy with
America and refuse to defend this
country and individual liberty I mean
there's nothing in the world that is
left to defend
I mean the only thing that is left is
evil dictatorships
so that's why I'm so heartbroken so you
write about this but what do you think
it is that that we can do to sort of
ignite that fire in people I mean I'm
you know obviously everyone knows in
Florida where you just were and you're
coming back pretty soon I mean it's here
there is a sense of let's fight for it
but we are losing a lot of the the
states at the moment
I think for the people to realize that
this is America's Our Moment On cultural
revolution is happening this is a silent
revolution in happening classrooms
incorporate businesses in the media it's
happening everywhere and we just don't
see it and media is aligned to us they
are changing entire Dynamic of this
country where somehow hate speech is a
violence therefore you have no right to
speak your mind and that's not the
definition of freedom people don't even
understand what it means to be American
and they're Americans like I became a
citizen last year and in my students
test my interviewer asking me have you
ever persecuted anybody for their poor
opinion if I said yes I could not become
American and that's what Google does
that's what Facebook does what Instagram
does and they were used to Twitter them
so these people have no idea what it
means to be American they are not
running these institutions and
brainwashing all of us to believe that
some this Authority and Rule is so much
better so I think that Revolution really
starts within individual liberty
individual responsibility that we need
to fight for our children's education we
need to you know start going to City
Hall meetings and show up and demand
what we deserve and what free country
should look like
how much of this do you think is being
directed by China that they just have so
much influence in our tech companies and
now in our government and you know that
that we know for a fact that Eric
swalwell has had a relationship with the
Chinese spy and nobody does anything
about it he's still in Congress I mean
is is this really just coming directly
from China just having us silence
ourselves pretty easy easier than
invading us
I mean this hijacking by the ccps
everywhere is that the Colombia gets the
money MIT gets money right the big media
gets money not only that the when my
first school was trying to become a
movie The Producer sent me a script and
the script is that China was my Promised
Land I was rescued by Chinese Authority
and they gave me a message I I called
the producer like what are you talking
about this is not what happened I was a
sex slave by 13 and he said this is the
only way we can make a movie in Korean
holidays wow
and that's when I realized even
Hollywood even just pure entertainment
is gone
so we cannot even fathom how much is
hijacked by China and just for instance
education I mean Healthcare the media
everything is on the Chinese control
right now and I don't think a lot of
people understand the gravity of this
this you know problem that we are facing
what do we do to wake people up to that
I mean they hear that sort of thing a
lot right more and more of us are
talking about it but you know it seems
like it's like this just we can't barely
deal with our own government much less
we have to deal with China
I think it's a first thing that we
realize we still have time to go back to
the glory of this country when people
meet me the first thing they usually
asking me like are North Koreans dumb
like where why there's no Revolution
they can just easily start Evolution why
you guys are putting up with this
totalitarian regime and if you stand up
in North Korea not only you get executed
the three to eight generations of your
family get executed and they do and they
get all get cared in America we are
currently don't get executed for saying
the wrong thing maybe we get censored we
call the racist and bigot and we lose
our job we lose our dignity but we still
the consequence of standing up is not
that as high Compared to North Korea
China the thing for us to realize that
even though there's a price to be paid
to be free and speak in your mind I
think all of us now do not probably this
a PC culture and in classrooms at work
everywhere we need to speak our mind and
we have to think for ourselves
can you talk a little bit about how this
has sort of affected you politically
because you know we're we're pretty good
friends actually we've had many many
meals together and and shot basketball
together and done a bunch of stuff
um but I I'm not that familiar with all
of your politics but I'm only asking
actually because it seems to me you're
being embraced by people sort of on the
right and being neglected by people on
the left even though the lefties would
say hey we're the ones for human rights
and all of those things uh yet in your
story that's not how this is playing out
something left their human rights means
fighting for free health care and free
education that is an insult to human
rights human rights means like right to
Liberty you know right to happiness and
pursue your your life but for them it's
all about free stuff from government and
their human rights means you know
fighting for their 10 000 different
genders they come up with it every day
that's what they say it's in the name of
Human Rights but they are fighting for
those causes and that's when I got this
delusioned these people don't even
understand what human rights means and
using that slogan every single day I was
talking about women's rights into human
rights and then for them what does it
mean women's rights is like we have a
right to cry in the boardrooms and we
should feel comfortable with that I'm
like do you know there are people
actually even
they don't understand
actual human rights means in the real
world and then the reason I became they
say I'm conservative I'm like I was
learning that from reading your book the
first book don't burn this book right
like what it means to be a classical
liberal that's who I am like I I mean
you're gay right I'm friends with so
many gay people too and I just live in
individual liberty and let them decide
and governments should not have power
over what people should do and what they
think
but being believing that somehow I'm a
far-riving currently and it seems that
most people within a common sense coming
to the right Camp because they are the
most tolerant Camp currently and I think
I fed into that because they accept me
they don't say you've been on a New York
Times therefore you have no right to
speak your mind when I go to Newton they
said that you've been on Fox we cannot
have you and recently my book just got
published with the same weekly Greta
Thunderbird
I saw the way more books than her and
her book is a new times bestselling list
and my book is not it have to use the
first book and it happened Jordan
Peterson and we expected that right
you're in good company my friend for the
record it did happen to my second book
we should have been number two in terms
of sales they didn't even put us on you
know I realized I mentioned I sort of
half threw away a comment that we played
basketball together I'm gonna have them
I'm gonna have my guys put the picture
of Enos Kanter uh picking you up and you
getting your first alley-oop was a
pretty beautiful
beautiful a beautiful beautiful moment
um but okay so you're sort of outside of
the machine because your story doesn't
fit their narrative have you found any
ways of making inroads with these people
that that seems to be the new thing that
if there's some way we can save some of
them and show them no you should be
about human rights before women's rights
or whatever it might be that that's the
group of people we want to bring with us
right now
yeah I think that's it that's the Hope
right there are so many people that we
can still save and they can still have
some kind of logic in them that they can
believe that this is this is not this is
wrong but in my book I was writing about
how I was invited by Jeff Bezos to go to
this like private Gathering of American
greatest and movers and shakers and he
flew me on the same path that you do
Harvey Weinstein
right before the metoo and then at the
heart I mean Jeff's event he gave a
speech and everybody stood up and giving
him like standing ovation and the woman
accused him with me too she was in the
in the sitting too and then calling him
the man and the legend
once the metabolism I call them like did
you guys know that he was actually
harassing women like of course we all
knew like did you not know the hypocrisy
they only talk about women's rights and
black lives matter when it's convenient
when there's actual consequences of
standing up for like dignity and freedom
they don't do that and one day I was
invited to by Tina Brown by Daily Beast
she invited me to uh join this private
gathering with the finance Pelosi
and then she was staying in this tribe
of the you know record dinner she was
saying she was going to impeach Trump
tomorrow morning
and then you're telling everybody you
know what to do and they're all these
business tycoons and finance people at
the same results in downtown in a
Midtown New York City and that means you
need to show the market because the
market markets will go down yeah right
if she is announcing that tomorrow
morning and by the time I was married to
a Trader I texted him like she's not
like you know Trump like is this even
legal is it not inside the trading
information it's like yeah that's
illegal
and that's when I understood the
corruption these people are not saying
they are not misled they know what
they're doing they're using this
ideology to control people and better
like their their position and gaining
more power
and that's when I got really special
illusion of the hypocrisy of American
Elite they don't care about anything
else other than themselves
do you think we're just kind of fat on
our freedoms that you can you know wave
the flag here you can ring the bell you
can do a dance and try to get everybody
to pay attention as many of us do but
that Americans we just we've all got the
iPhone they've got the you know
PlayStation 5 and whatever else is
distracting them and that really is the
reason that not enough people will ever
step up until until it's too late
yeah that's the thing there's a tick
tock right there's a difference there's
a social media platforms and all this
Netflix everything distracting us we are
so busy getting entertained by this
empty stuff and that is a very toxic a
lot of times and people have stopped
reading books they have stopped
understanding what the meaning of
enlightenment and what it means to be in
the individual so I think the problem is
a lot bigger than I think what I've seen
currently and raising a child like it's
really scary thing right now currently
in America and I think that's why I said
my child now Catholic school and send
him to church
I think at some point it's beyond us and
one thing that I know whenever there is
a Commerce Revolution the first thing
they do is going after religion
and that is very scary right now how
much religion is getting attacked in
America and the people have no like if
you are somehow Christian you are like
being bullied that you're stupid bigot
and in North Korea I know they they kill
the God and they became God right and
they became the most evil God so yeah I
mean at the end of the day I just do
everything I can do in my power and just
have to pray yeah I want to back up to
what you said earlier about living in
New York City as a as an Asian woman
obviously I don't want to play identity
politics but there really is a rash of
violence against Asian people uh even
when I was there last week there was a
story about an Asian woman just being
you know basically mauled on the subway
random guy no no purpose didn't steal
anything literally just violence for the
sake of violence
How concerned are you and do you feel
like anyone in New York is going to do
anything about it
so it happened to me several times as
some guys come up and just help me
and I'm just so like you know freaked
out like I don't even know what to say I
don't even know what it figures that man
shoot me right like these people are not
even I don't think they're in their same
mind at this point everybody is on their
Fentanyl and drugs are everywhere like I
used to live in Manhattan now just moved
out to Queens the ketan is 32nd Broadway
it's almost like Asian Community we
don't have drugs there now they're the
drug lords sending selling these like
drugs in the purple rap looks like
lollipop and my son thinks it's a role
if he asked me to buy him that and
that's a drug and there's a COPS stand
there do nothing about it right they're
just standing there doing nothing
and I think this is why I'm just so
curious why Americans are okay with the
their countries being ruined and somehow
there's so much resentment to America in
in their mind in their mind that America
deserve to get dismantled and destroyed
and maybe that's why they are not doing
anything because if you are if you love
your country in any little possible way
you cannot be sitting there and your
heart is not broke yeah and then at the
same time they'll gladly take someone
like you and throw you under the bus as
you as you fight to give them the
freedoms that they're you know in
essence squandering uh do you do you
find that uh some of the Allies uh
should do more I mean what else what
else should guys like me be doing and
the people that you are able to connect
with and talk to what should we be doing
to to keep fighting no I'm internally
grateful when I was getting Shadow
banned and censored everywhere the
locals gave me coming
right I mean now the tutor got freaked
but I mean you guys did that before
where like we had no place to go speak
our minds and it was so in a way so
oppressive like you know country you
expected to have a freedom of choice and
voices and we didn't have that so I
think people like you being
entrepreneurs and finding opportunities
to give people freedom and make things
better I think that's very important so
thank you so much for the for the
lockers trying trying you know I mean
thank you more importantly for
everything you're doing
um what else is in the book that people
may not know about
either your story or what you're
fighting for right now
legal agenda I didn't know what left or
what I meant that's like you know I
didn't even know what America's looked
like yeah so coming here I was in the
arms of the like really liberal left
right they penguin giving me training
say don't ever talk about what you think
about second amendments because somebody
was asking me when I came to America
what do you think about people owning
guns I was like that's a fantastic thing
because imagine if North Koreans had
guns I was not going to let them take my
father like that
we are not gonna let them kill our Asian
regions of family when you die and
you're gonna fight your death there's no
country can be ever be that enslaved
when they have guns to defend their
rights and even cameras in Cambodia the
before the general side the first thing
they did was taking all the guns from
the people
so my desire for owning that gun is a
lot deeper than just like some school
shootings right it's not about that and
people were like just don't ever ever
say that in public and they were like
what do you like to say I'd like to read
like what they like to read that's like
I love to be the bastias the law Jones
theater on Liberty and they were like I
can see where this is going yeah yeah
just don't say that and back then I
didn't even know why I was not allowed
to say that and because penguin I guess
wanted to protect me before I get
blindly left they just didn't want me to
do that and they will keep begging me to
write about
how hard it is to be a woman you know
how oppressed that the woman in living
life and how America is so oppressed to
the black men putting them in the camps
which is like same thing with two North
Korean like political prison camp I'm
like that's not even the same thing
right if you call the political prison
Kevin North Korea you don't make it even
until three months these people keep
going and keep coming back on that's a
problem
so I think that's the people don't
understand like I I was not so nice
trained by CIA and giving this message I
was a pure just person coming here and
seeing the tendencies that I was seeing
in North Korea happen in America and
it's coming from a I don't know it's a
really genuine place like people don't
recognize this pattern because they
never see no true oppression and I see
the same pattern and tactics and if
there is something called the ridiculous
handbook right and I feel like that's
what America is doing right now they're
going through this manual handbook and
to how to control full citizens and
they're playing playing all the tactics
coming from every angle
are you hopeful I mean despite
everything you're describing here in a
sort of shock to Coming to America and
and seeing a you know you came in a time
when it was we were in this kind of
upheaval but are you hopeful that we can
do the right thing here
yeah if we have if we do five for our
Second Amendment
I think we are never gonna be the state
of North Korea in China that's for sure
I don't even know how many generations
can stand that understanding the meaning
of self-defense you know they think so
my governments keep brainwashing them
the guns are the battle and they are
school shootings right that's the
brainwashing you keep going through and
eventually what Innovation didn't stop
understanding the meaning of having a
gun and give that up and that I don't
know so that's the thing like other than
being pessimistic optimistic doesn't
really irrelevant I know what's the
right thing to do I know I it's my
responsibility as a mother to turn my
son what I know about the world right
that's our responsibility being an adult
educating our children about the things
that we understand so they can't go
further understanding new things but we
have been failing at that we've been
failing our children and not teaching
them the things that we understand and I
think that's why coming from this new
generation believing that they're
oppressed living America and they will
destroy this country because you know
this country is bigoted and they just
heard that from their teachers it's
nothing about based on actual truth
I was going to ask you to sum this all
up nicely but I don't know that you can
do it any better than that do you have
any final thoughts no I mean that's all
I think you know we just have to do the
right things nothing about being hopeful
being you know like anything about just
do the right thing and that is telling
the truth and speaking up against Power
the book is what time remains which is
just a perfect title too because there's
urgency there's urgency because before
you know it it's gone beyond me I look
forward to seeing you in the Free State
of Florida sometime soon yes see you
soon
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell